wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
der bruder arbeitet in deutschland ja
das hat ein paar jahren ja danach eigene
firma und warum will dass du denkst oder
spanien gibt
er macht immer was meine eltern sagen
pippi interessiert sich überhaupt nicht
für mich ich bin für ihn egal du bist
ihm egal
ich bin da wirklich optimal bruder kam
jetzt richtig nicht so über ihn auch
hier hat er hausverbot
was warner bros
ein brief von der schule auch eine
antwort
ich trage mich nicht es ist bestimmt nur
zu sagen dass china das ist ein brief
genau das ist ein umschlag und das ist
die briefmarke dann schreibst du die
adresse auf den oben schlag und wirfst
den brief dann in den briefkasten
ich hoffe dass da noch mal zeit für ein
foto bringen
ich freue mich auf dem projekt sich
machen wird
ein mädchen pizza zur feier des tages
ich möchte bitte eine salami pizza
[Musik]